what is interesting is the manipulative side
and
personal interactive experience has developed
the intuition of the mathematical concept
work at natixis
in the financing bank in
equity derivatives i am responsible for
scientific computing
i have a team of  about twenty
people who take care of
the integration of eds pricer
programs for calculating the price of
optional products so some of
these people therefore
integrate the pricers in such a way
that it goes into production
without problems and another  part
deals with the calculation of sensitivities
and stress tests so cds derivatives
small variation is a small delta
stress tests are big
market data shocks that we try on Easter
we simulate to see what is going on
arrive at the portfolio of
financial products that we have to manage
if there is a big problem
in the market
I used it during an
internal program called camp  us
earnings is a kind of university a
term with a number of
assignments so i offered
to teach a session on
local volatility so it's
something that's a concept that was
ten discovered at  beginning of the 90s
which is not necessarily mastered by
everyone which is therefore if we attack with
pure traditional math in the end we
are we have a big obstacle to overcome
before having an intuition of what it
is therefore the session that I  I proposed
it is therefore the volatility the
local volatility without the math
so these facts based on a
math manipulator the way we want to
present I use the local flight it is
through the methods of monte carlo
so the methods  of monte carlo are
extremely
computational so spend a lot
of machine energy let's say that there is a
lot more but on this
experience there the interactive graphics
via the manipulators and the controls
the ease of development  because
it is an interpreter
so the speed thanks to the compilation
that it is a very
interesting characteristic of mathematics to be able to
compile in c is to be able to execute the
result